[Music]
one of the things i always tell people
because it was my experience is that in
order to get the deliberate practice
aspect of skill acquisition applied to
writing like if you want to get better
at writing fast you have to be writing
for editing and you have to be writing
in the context of acceptance and
rejections
because writing is one of these things
where everyone can do it well enough
that if you're mainly just writing on
your own so i'm writing in a journal
i'm writing a blog i'm doing national
novel writing month it's just me you
know working on my novel you don't
necessarily get that stretch that's
going to improve your skills and so the
thing that mattered for me is that i was
writing for editing and for acceptance
and rejection so for editing meaning
writing for an editor you have a you
have a reader an editor who's going to
edit it and also will reject it if it's
not good and so this is actually why
writing for the the humor publication
was a big deal i mean you probably
remember from your time in ivy league
schools in particular there's a real
culture around humor writing because it
used to be
you know back in the days where
everything was the the sort of old old
boys network the vast majority of of
comedy writers for shows like snl or or
the tonight show they were a lot they
were coming out of these ivy league
humor societies what is the name of the
humor magazine at dartmouth at dartmouth
it's the jack-o'-lantern the
jack-o-lantern and people may
have heard
the
term lampoon the lampoon is is that of
harvard and then you have a number of
different magazines at princeton and so
on yeah exactly and then they all have
these huge old histories you know so
like dr seuss
did cartoons for the dartmouth
jack-o'-lantern in the 1920s and you
know anyways
so that's a very competitive world you
would pitch pieces and if they were
funny they would go so they would back
then it would be you know print
magazines you would pitch pieces and if
they were funny enough they would get in
if they weren't they wanted it it was it
was just starkly competitive and then i
wrote a humor column for the paper but
it's the same thing to become a
columnist they would say no no no yeah
we'll do that one no yeah we'll do that
one and if you got five in the paper
you had the
possibility of doing a columns so i
think that really stretched my skill
and that helped that helped and and you
know i'll say the two things that help
my writing the most
to your original point here is
a humor writing turns out to be
incredibly useful
for any type of writing because humor
writing is all about the the timing the
pacing and the music of the words you
have to replicate the timing of a
stand-up comedian
using grammar and word choice and having
to get the right rhythm to set up the
punch line way to beat and nail it you
have to do that all with words
that gives you an incredible facility
with sentence crafting and so i mean
i'll tell you like today as a writer for
the new yorker which is very craft
focused you know they really care
writing craft is a really big deal over
at the new yorker the training i did as
a human writer
is incredibly applicable because you
hear you hear the words as music and the
pausing and the rhythm it's you have to
actually the performance of the reading
you think a lot about it and
that actually really helps over there
and then mathematics just like
programming
that has been the other key to my
success because if you do proofs for
example
it's you develop this sense where uh
it's not right this doesn't work the
pieces don't fit and then when the piece
is fit it's the the chorus of angels
right like your mind is like i don't
like when things don't quite fit and
when they do
it's dopamine coming out of your ears
it led to my style of writing which is
my advice right is very intricate you
know it's
lay out the generative theory that lays
out these pieces and these pieces all
fit together and you might not notice it
consciously when you read it but part of
the experience of my writing is that all
of the pieces i'm laying out there all
click together into a hole where
everything fits nicely and this is
symmetric with this and this makes sense
here and nothing is hanging out and it
reduces this cognitive drag that happens
sometimes when writing's a little bit
less the ideas are a little bit less
formed and it makes it harder to write
but i think that's been a bit of a
secret sauce in my work is that it's
it's cognitively pleasing
because your brain appreciates the fact
that sort of nerdishly and obsessively
all the pieces actually fit together
you